charity navigator which is a website for
determining which charities operate the
most effectively they've come out with
an annual study of CEO pay where they
ranked people and it's a it's a long
list but 11 charities pay their CEO is
over a million dollars and we just we
picked a couple of them here five let's
take a look so these are charities that
pay more pay their ceos and their
leaders American 1,000,000 attorney so
American universities they're like
foundation oh metropolitan museum of art
the heritage foundation that's a your
buddy what's his name jim demint yeah
the National Center for Missing and
Exploited Children and the boys and
girls club yeah that's that Larry on you
know I've been to Boys and Girls Clubs
okay Oh horrible they are so all right
bro spare I mean it's a great service
where you can have a place for your kids
to come basically for free and play and
be and you know and have you know being
a good surroundings but they're really
they're not pretty they're not dirty but
they're not pretty yeah what's served to
them in forms of snacks are not great
right and for that charity so the CEO
there is making over a million dollars
just I think that's disproportionate
yeah so the median CEO salary for all
the ones that charity navigator looked
at was about a hundred twenty six
thousand dollars for large charities
that had more than 13.5 million in
annual expenses the median pay was two
hundred and forty four thousand dollars
but this seems completely crazy right
now I think what they're they would
argue is they need the best of the best
yeah yeah that's what they would argue
and that otherwise you get this brain
drain because if you don't pay the CEOs
enough that you're not going to get the
right people in that can make it as good
of an organism that's what Mother Teresa
used to say no I want to work with but I
mentally we got a baby yeah I pay me
show me that is the brain drain argument
you use don't buy that it
any level whatsoever not for chair no
you go to work for a charity because I
mean there's lots of committed people
that's all [ __ ] that's about people
wanting more money yeah I'm being greedy
taking a million dollars with my [ __ ]
charity right that is quick so that's
twenty thousand dollars a week right 27
yeah that's 20,000 wow it is yes a week
so that's five thousand dollars a day
right right that's more than [ __ ] makes
move well you know like that one no I
defended maybe I'm naive but I guess I
expect someone who works for a charity
to have some amount of altruism yes and
um at this level but also yeah you know
what is too much daddy really depends on
what your perspective is i mean like i
could say yeah i think that if they make
like 250 thousand dollars a year i think
that's a that's a fair amount but like
Who am I to say that I think you're you
go I think you're just as qualified as
anyone else to say that I i would say
that i would say that he will give you a
salary that puts you in the upper two
percent is that enough right is that
enough so that's the question with these
people that are doing this for over a
million dollars right not do it for five
hundred thousand languages and girls
clubs that have a million yeah i'm going
back i'll go back to work for a tobacco
that's right yeah so can we just not
play on on the good missin people is
that where does it also also look at
what people in the movies make i mean
like is that is that fair for somebody
to make 20 million dollars for a movie
no but for them there at least saying
they do it for themselves right there's
no illusion that they're somehow doing
it for the better right right right well
i guess a lot of actors probably think
they're doing it well right what would
you say to be with that Judge Dredd yeah
hi just awful yeah I thank this [ __ ]
when I hear about that it's a scam a
million dollars that people donate go to
your own pocket that yeah well yeah so
the definition of charity I thought this
was interesting is the voluntary giving
of help typically in the form of money
to those in need so actually by giving
these people salaries that are menos
you're actually going against the very
finition of chair of the word so what do
we do do we just not give money to these
I mean those organizations doing some
good stuff maybe not the hurried you
know what when I get tired to do a
charity event I usually donate the money
back to the charity you know that's
that's as a performer right and
communists hahaha radical so I said
usually taught the big ones not enough
it's a big check not today but we're
disaffected for list oh absolutely yeah
i would i would not yet give to these
particular charities yeah i mean i
wouldn't give to the heritage foundation
anyway right but I mean the Boys and
Girls Club is something that I think is
a great service but I would want them to
know I would want them to know that I'm
not giving because of this information
yeah is part of probable so that people
think that he's not for profit companies
that they're all altruistic but you can
be not-for-profit and make a ton of
money right your CEOs and all your high
level people can get paid a ton you
don't not profitable marijuana clinics
yeah I think that's how it works I think
they can take a salary and that they
have to be nonprofits technically I
think info California anyway so does
that mean that that aside from just
paying salaries that all the money goes
back to the sir yeah it's not going back
in to pay like dividends and things like
right that's not right right okay well I
guess the point of this was that you
should put your money in the medical
marijuana a snake away of what he was
trying today they were helping Jekyll
forget that just straight to us that's
right straight here we can buy our pods
we're trailer to your local comedians I
think that
the Reuben report brought to you by
Koopa com they've got up to seventy-five
percent off cat and dog treats toys and
more you can get another twenty percent
off using code RR the link is right down
below click it and make your pet happy